et du cinéma avec l affiche mardi
prochain deux stars d'hollywood sean
penn et michel schaeffer réunis dans un
film bouleversant sa main mais l'eau
comme savent en faire les américains
shon peine il montre toute sa mesure en
incarnant un handicapé mental qui se bat
pour garder sa petite fille sabine gorny
ce n'est qu'il est laid qui soit comme
ça pousse et mexicains qu'est ce que tu
veux dire par là qui est différent
préparez vos mouchoirs car à moins
d'avoir un coeur de pierre mousserie
nous larmes devant ce combat désespéré
d'un papa mentalement attardés pour
garder sa petite lou si que les services
sociaux veulent lui enlever samse sean
penn bouleversant parce qu'il évite la
caricature pour ce rôle tout en nuances
il a passé des semaines dans une
association de handicapés a observé fait
j'ai pris çà et là des attitudes bêtise
des comportements au sperme en personne
à temps j'ai aussi beaucoup appris des
deux comédiens handicapés qui joue dans
le film sam va trouver le soutien d'une
ambitieuse avocat d'affaires la belle
michelle pépère pour plaider ce droit à
l'amour un peu trop glamour pour qu'on y
croit tout à fait mais la star elle
aussi n'est pas sorti indemne de ce
tournage n'est pas tout à fait comme les
autres
ce monde du handicap me faisait vraiment
peur avant le tournage
par ignorance j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai
changé aussi avoir l'air de quelqu'un
normale en mai lowe's certes avec happy
end à l'attelé qui a le mérite pourtant
de poser de vraies questions de société
très touchant c'est vrai que son
situations qu'on retrouve en france et
avant même la question de la parentalité
on peut aussi se poser la question de la
sexualité des personnes handicapées
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
tous vous avez un accueil je suis un
vrai adultes des stars poids lourd
beaucoup d'amour et d'humour sur fond de
droit à la différence
question violon émotions hollywood s'y
connaît reste la magnifique performance
de sean penn bouleversant au pape a
déchiré digne et beau à pleurer